joining us on the hotline right now john
beck former nfl quarterback for the
dolphins and the washington football
team he was a second round pick
in that jamarcus russell draft and he is
now
one of the premier quarterback coaches
in all of the land he is coaching three
guys
who should be top 10 picks uh he's also
coaching kyle
trask uh who could potentially sneak
into the first round i
had the pleasure of uh catching up with
john uh
a couple of weeks ago down in huntington
beach where he trains all these guys and
he's in michigan right now doing more
work he's all over the
country training guys john thanks for
joining us yeah you're welcome
what's uh what what's going on in
michigan you working with nfl guys high
school guys college guys what's going on
there
uh just paying a visit one of my old
coaches uh at the ravens
is uh now at the university of michigan
so uh
catching up talking quarterbacks and
then on my way now to uh cleveland
heading down for the draft to be with
zach and his family
and that must be so awesome for you to
uh be able to be a part of that with uh
with these guys zach wilson expected to
be
the number two overall pick to the jets
and you've been working with zach
longer than any of these other guys uh
share with us how that relationship came
to fruition
well zach was coming out of high school
he graduated early went to byu
i actually met him through his uncle who
was bringing
his son out to train with us and it was
just one of those
circumstances where he's like hey my
nephew's uh playing at byu right now
he's just gonna be in spring ball i'd
love to set him up with you i think his
family would really like this and zach
would like it and that was the
beginnings of it so
this moment right now to be able to come
to the nfl draft
and see somebody that i've known for
three years i got to see
the starting point for him in college
football we worked together
before he'd even thrown his first
completed pass in a collegiate game so
it's been
really cool to see from a starting point
like that
to now this unbelievable point that's
going to start his nfl career
really cool and his story has been
talked about leading up to the draft was
in a three-way quarterback competition
during covid last year would drive down
from utah to southern california to work
with you
obviously been with you for a while as
you mentioned was delivering
doordash in utah and california after
workouts just to
make some extra coin and no idea he
would even be entering the draft he was
just trying to win a starting uh
job again and have a good season
and you and i talked about this on my
podcast
at what point during the season did you
realize this this kid could not only be
entering the draft this year he could be
a first round draft pick
i want to say it was after those first
like three to four games
i think the national buzz just really
picked up because west of texas nobody
was playing football
so here you have byu with an espn
contract
uh all of their games were on prime tv
on saturdays
and so the whole entire country's
getting to watch zach go out there and
just make these spectacular plays and
finish games
sometimes he was like 23 of 26 for 300
yards and four touchdowns like
he threw more touchdowns than he had
incompletions and all of a sudden it's
like
the whole nation's saying well wait a
second who's this guy and i want to say
it was after game four
something like that that uh mel kiper
put out his top five quarterbacks for
the nfl draft and i think zach came up
at like number four
and i remember having conversations with
his dad saying
this is legitimately gonna happen
because zach's gonna keep playing well
this buzz is gonna keep growing
and if he's already on this list right
now it's going to be really difficult
for him
to go back to school he's just he's
really talented he's put in all the work
and i remember his dad being like i
don't know
if it like it's like we didn't plan on
this like i don't even
i wasn't expecting have to make a
decision and i remember the conversation
going
this decision may already be made for
you just because the position zach may
be in
going into this draft dan helly filling
in for rich eisen talking to uh former
nfl quarterback now quarterback coach uh
one of the real
best quarterback coaches out there john
beck uh we're discussing zach wilson
who's expected to be the number two
overall pick to the new york jets this
is a a utah
kid uh who wanted to go to utah ends up
at byu
he's going to go to the big apple and
he's going to have to be the savior
that's what they're going to expect him
to be he seems very
very dialed in to have a great head on
his shoulders but i think
john as you know that that's culture
shock for anybody that hasn't been in
that situation before
you know you were a second run pick you
went to miami you played in a big market
in washington
they have you to lean on how have you
advised him in terms of how to handle
this process
i think i would remind him it's a
process we've had this talk before right
um just because he's picked high doesn't
guarantee
success there's a lot of people that are
picked high and they're
they're talented they're qualified to be
that high pick and there's a lot of
reasons why
it should equal success but it's not
guaranteed like that especially in the
nfl
um getting picked tied gives you an
opportunity to
for a team to develop you right it buys
you a little bit of time
you still have to go out there and make
plays on sundays you still have to find
ways to win the tight ball games
and it's at the highest level of
competition pro football is the toughest
because of the level of competition on
the field there's so many great athletes
the wins are usually by such narrow
margins each play has such an impact
quarterbacks can play an efficient game
and that doesn't guarantee victory
uh all that efficient games do is give
you a chance
and everything comes down to wins and
losses it's a high-stakes game in the
nfl where a lot of times people's jobs
are on the line and because of that
the pressure mounts the expectations
mount and it can be a difficult
environment to play in
because of that all the things that i
just described to some ears listening
that may seem daunting to other people
like what i believe zach wilson is this
type of person
it is a challenge i believe most the men
that are in the nfl are men that
love challenges same with the coaches
they love the challenge of things
and it excites them and motivates them
it drives them so really what going to
the new york jets is is it's a challenge
and there's going to be a host of
uh adversity there's going to be a lot
of things along the way that he's going
to have to adapt
grow learn new tools sharpen his tools
that he already has
like go back to the drawing board after
a loss that's all going to happen and
what you hope for and you cross your
fingers for is that during all that
crazy ride there's good development
there's good consistency and all those
things grow to a place where then
the new york jets get to turn this thing
around and make a playoff run and that's
when it gets really exciting
you also work with justin fields who
going into the season
seemingly the consensus number two
quarterback uh
in this draft zach kind of bumped him
from that spot
and now fields where he lands
might be the biggest question mark in
the draft it could be
anywhere from let's say atlanta
to who knows and you've worked with him
for a while what what is
his best trait and are you surprised
that so many people are attempting to
kind of poke holes in his game
i'm not surprised that they're poking
holes that's the name of the game at
this point
in the process when somebody enters this
thing already really high
all the things that have already pushed
them high have already happened so the
only thing that's left to do is to poke
holes and find reasons why a guy
shouldn't be high
it's kind of funny how that works
sometimes you have like these light
risers and late fallers
well the guy hasn't changed right
everything that made him high at the
beginning
has that all gone away no it hasn't so
they poke holes at him
and sometimes these guys that are called
late risers they really haven't
done something to make the rise happen
it's just maybe people have investigated
them a little bit more and been like oh
wow
this was always here to begin with so i
don't think there's been any reason that
justin shouldn't still be considered a
top pick
i've said that a number of times on a
bunch of interviews that i've done his
best
quality i believe is demonstrated in
that clemson game
he went out on the biggest stage and in
that moment he delivered
an amazing game and he did it playing
through an injury you want to talk about
what nfl quarterbacks have to do
that's it right there you only get to
play one game of the year perfectly
healthy the first game of the year
after that most nfl quarterbacks are
dealing with something
i can't tell you how many years drew
brees played with something that nobody
knew about
and he was playing through those all of
the time and that's why
other quarterbacks have a lot of respect
for guys like that phillip rivers played
a playoff game with a torn mcl
you have to do that to be an nfl
quarterback so i just look at what
justin did right there
that's the epitome of an nfl quarterback
finding a way to succeed
late in the season and to me that's his
biggest and best quality and that's why
i think teams should definitely be
paying attention to him
and he's still up there for that third
pick i don't know who the third pick is
going to be
i know that they've investigated three
guys they've done a lot of homework on
those three guys and they're gonna make
a pick tomorrow night
but i think he's definitely worthy of
that pick as is
those other guys it could be the fourth
pick it could be whoever trades up
he could go a bunch of places but i do
think as a football player he's done a
phenomenal job
through his playing days and he's done
everything right since his last game
that third pick of course belongs to the
san francisco 49ers they traded two
firsts and a third to move up from 12 to
three
for that pick and all indications and
reports out there are that they're
leaning heavily towards mack jones
also uh they have investigated justin
fields as you mentioned and trey lance
who you have also worked with it is an
unbelievable stable of talent
at the quarterback position that you've
worked with this year when it comes to
trey
and this was reported out there so we're
not breaking any news here
but kyle shanahan wanted him to work
with you so however that was that
information was
was transferred or translated you ended
up working
with trey lance how was that uh
relationship been
and what do you see working with tree
lands for the couple of weeks that you
have
well first off i've been super grateful
for the opportunity to work with all
these guys a name that was left off
there was kyle traff
um who's also a guy that could sneak
into the first round and kj costello
all those guys regardless of draft order
i feel tremendously best
blessed to be in that position to work
with that caliber of guys and to be
around them as they go through this
journey
the draft process journey is one that
they've looked forward to their entire
life
so i just feel it it's a humbling
experience to get to have those guys and
i love the challenge that it is for me
to try to help guys that are already on
that level become better it's why i love
my job and the work we do for pros
trey lance is an exceptional uh talent
he's gonna bring a lot of things to the
table i know that everybody's already
talked about it before right the limited
games
playing in north dakota state all of
those things i'll tell you what he does
bring to the table
he brings to the table this energy and
eagerness to improve he brings this
a great skill set he's a big dude i had
no idea how big he was he walks out on
the field and i'm going good crap
i didn't realize watching tape of him
how big he was and he's athletic for how
big he is
he's a smart guy you get on the field
and you talk through things with him it
shows
the way that he played within his system
the way that he navigated and controlled
the things at the line of scrimmage in
terms of protections
changing plays he understands really
well why the coach
called the plays that's another trait
that i've described in justin fields
that i think is a standout trait of his
he knows why ryan day was calling plays
and he recognized when an opportunity
for that shot was there he was able to
deliver on it trey has that ability
i think there's a reason why guys are
intrigued by somebody coming from a
place
like north dakota states because what he
brings and i know that there's intrigue
right uh
the 49ers have absolutely done a lot of
homework on trey he could very well be
the pick
um and i think if he is the pick i know
people may say well what has he done
okay it's not just about what he's done
in college
like he showed enough he put together an
undefeated season yes he could have
thrown the ball a little bit more but
when you're winning every single game
why do you have to go out there and
throw the ball more some people may be
critical and say well that game that he
got to play this year didn't
look like how it should okay say that
not every single game in a quarterback's
you know career is going to look exactly
how it should but dude i know firsthand
battled back from a lot of things to
even just get that one game he fought
hard for his team so to me it
demonstrated leadership
and all these guys i can tell you yeah
of course you're going to poke holes
there
and that's valid and all those
quarterbacks know the second they put on
a jersey that has the nfl logo on it
that's going to happen for the rest of
their career whether it's a good or bad
performance if the outcome isn't a win
people are going to poke at them poke
out and poke at them that just comes at
the territory
but i love so many of the things that
trey kyle
zak justin all these guys bring to the
table
you have so many relationships uh around
the nfl when you were in washington you
played on
uh mike shanahan's team kyle was the
offensive coordinator you had matt
lafleur who was there
you also had sean mcveigh who was there
your phone has been ringing off the hook
from coaches and general managers around
the national football league
these quarterbacks and their agents hire
you to train them to get them prepared
for the next level how do you balance
out when
these these coaches and gm's are calling
you for an honest assessment
on the quarterbacks that you're working
with when you're hired by these
quarterbacks to work with them how do
you balance it out
so i have a long-standing relationship
with those coaches and they're going to
trust the feedback that i give them
and i have to i have to give the real
feedback so that it's always
credible um i can't sugarcoat things to
the coaches
and here's the main reason why if that
coach drafts that person
i want them to know exactly who they're
getting right
positives things they got to work on
things that like maybe they that need to
be enhanced
i'm going to give them the reality of
who that person is at their draft
because i believe
reality gives you the best chance for
growth i believe that this is just a
thing across
all human uh growth and development when
you're
looking at yourself from a perspective
that is not real
you limit your ability to grow right why
is feedback so important
because within the feedback you get it's
usually an outside source giving you
real feedback that you may not see
yourself a lot of times in life we hear
these things called blind spots
i need somebody to make me aware of my
blind spots right so
maybe this agent who is super high on
this draft pick they pick them right
and they would love to only have all of
the the great things be shared about
them
but the reality is i'm helping both the
player and the agent
by giving the coach the reality of who
that player is
because if that coach drafts them i
don't look at it that if i share
something real
that oh my gosh what if that guy doesn't
take him what if that guy does take him
and doesn't know those things
he thinks he's getting something else
and i don't want that coach to think
that and i don't want
the player to have that expectations on
his shoulder that he's supposed to be
something more
than what he really is because that's
been trying to be too perfect he has to
know exactly
who he's getting so i share that with
the coaches and i think that that's why
they respect my feedback because i'm not
going to just give them some fairy tale
of
well here's all the great things about
the guy you should just go draft him no
no i'm going to tell you all the things
that if you do pick him
here's exactly where he needs to grow
but if you do pick him i'll
also tell you why the reasons i believe
he can succeed i think that's so on
point dan helly filling in for rich
eisen talking to former nfl quarterback
john beck
who is the quarterback coach for five
quarterbacks
in this year's nfl draft including zach
wilson
including justin fields and trey lance
kyle trask also on that list
kg costello out of mississippi state on
that list as well 32 teams
in the nfl 32 teams involved in the
draft
how many of those teams out of 32 john
have reached out to you to ask you
questions about the quarterbacks you're
working with
oh my gosh i haven't kept track you know
the tough part for me is on all those
pro days
every single pro that i go to the
majority of teams are in attendance
and really it's the teams that you know
are potentially going quarterback right
so they have like
their offensive coordinator their
quarterback coach their gm
i'll see those guys at the pro day then
they'll reach out to me afterwards
or there's some teams that like hey a
certain coach couldn't be at the pro day
because of the numbers
but he still wants to talk to me so i
don't have like a list
and it's not necessarily about the 32
teams and the number of those guys it's
more about
the teams that are potentially looking
at quarterbacks all of those teams that
are potentially looking at quarterbacks
um have reached out oh there's only one
team that i really don't have a lot of
strong ties to and that's the new
england patriots
um i only hear about stuff i don't talk
to anybody specifically
uh within their building and uh you know
a lot of it has to just come down to
ties maybe there's people that are
already in their guys corner those
quarterbacks corner like connected to
the agents that have
ties there that's like the only team
within those quarterback teams that are
looking at guys that i haven't spoken to
this year
john beck quarterback coach for three
potential top ten picks kyle trask who
could sneak into the first round
he also worked with justin herbert uh
still does matthew stafford jared goff
matt ryan the laundry list of
quarterbacks that you work with
is unrivaled and he has become uh one of
the very best quarterback coaches in the
game right now
john good luck in michigan the rest of
the way can i add something there real
quick is that okay
absolutely a like anytime somebody
mentions the quarterbacks that we train
i feel like it can't go without saying
the guys that i work with
at 3d qb it's more than just me on a
day-to-day basis for the last five years
it's been myself
adam dado uh and taylor kelly we are the
team
of 3dqb so you know i can't do an
interview where we say all these guys
that we work with because my partners
they also run point on so many of those
guys was the point man
for so many of those guys the matt
staffords the matt ryan
you know the the carson wentz all those
guys that's that like that's adam he's
an incredible coach
does an amazing job doesn't get to do
all the interviews like i get to do
because of my ties to the nfl
and taylor kelly as well i can't tell
you how many guys come to us
also because of the outstanding job that
those guys do and that's really the team
at 3dqb we've been able to learn a lot
over the years work with a lot of great
people that's who we are
well it's it's an amazing team i know
you've been working with adam for a long
time and
taylor of course a former quarterback at
uh arizona state the team at uh 3dqb is
certainly doing something right
and hopefully all your guys end up
fat and happy so to speak uh after draft
night and where they want to go because
you have a lot of guys who are going to
be in
prime time positions john thank you so
much for the time really appreciate it
if you want to listen to uh more with
john beck an incredibly insightful
interview on my podcast the uh
the helipod is up right now john thanks
man yeah you're welcome buddy we'll see
you
all right talk soon hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here